dry off tears of laughter on a doggie
derriere with one of these animal but
towel holders after frightening the
whole neighborhood with your oversized
lifelike David Hasselhoff model because
it's episode 39 of loot illuminate your
world by grabbing a butt lamp slap it is
a series of two she touching lights for
your wall that come in a variety of
colors but they're currently only
available in 50 limited editions the
first meal of the day is important so
put it on your face using the breakfast
face care pack their powder masks that
will leave your skin smooth thanks to
oak brazen yogurt and cafe mocha then
stuff your face with adorable zombie
bunny chocolate that will hop along
great with goat brain beer created by
Doc Street brewery in honor of the
walking dead for something Undead that's
a little more personal keep your very
own zombie in a necklace that will hang
around in style on this sloth Kong
sweater now that you're dressed it's
time to play so open up your ping pong
table door and slam dunk in your kitchen
thanks to the basketball hoop fridge
magnet but if your dunking with a cup of
coffee in your hand use the incredible
spill not so you don't lose a drop
thanks to physics for the hungry
business professional on the go cook
using the portable briefcase grill
designed to look like a vintage
briefcase and then have dessert in this
shake and make ice cream device that
makes delicious creations and around 3
minutes using the impressive power of
your hands impress your friends with
these mystery box cards designed with
the help of JJ Abrams the box is made
from 100 year old reclaimed wood and
contains 12 decks of mystery playing
cards locked with an alphanumeric
combination and they donate $1 per pack
soul to a nonprofit that promotes
creative writing in schools you must be
exhausted from all that awesome so take
a nap in your personal bunkie these are
106 square foot preassembled mini houses
that are made to go anywhere and don't
require a building permit they can be
customized to include a fireplace
queen-size Murphy bed
modular cabinetry but unfortunately
there's no running water or just go live
under a banana umbrella like the one you
ride around with thanks to this
convenient bike banana holder then take
a chance and gamble with dinner using
food dice that offer 186,000 recipe
combinations but be sure to keep supper
super classy using these wooden wine
glasses or just keep it simple and have
some cheese and verse and crackers make
a one-of-a-kind statement with your
custom phone or tablet skin from
creative skin calm that lets you choose
one of their many hand painted designs
or upload a picture yourself maybe you
can get one design that looks like a
fire-breathing dragon a
remote-controlled jet-powered
fire-breathing dragon to be precise that
can help you rule the skies for sixty
thousand dollars first let me plug that
in to charge it Oh knows you didn't just
insult me with the Shakespeare insult
generator like some kind of obscene rum
fed horn beast figure out what time it
is mathematically by solving some clock
problems then determine what bull penis
cane you want wait what no never mind
that just put your favorite picture in
this pixel frame finally relax your
meaty head on a chicken drumstick pillow
because you probably need some space
t-shirt
the folks at beardo were so happy to be
featured in the previous episode of loot
they said hey we want to give a few
lucky fans some stuff to which I said
let's give everyone stuff and they said
that sounds awesome
so for the rest of April get 15% off at
beardo we're calm using the code Vsauce
- so you can finally have your hat and
bearded - and as always thanks for
watching